C'est une histoire d'amitié entre une fille et un garçon.
Une histoire d'amitié sans ambiguïté.
On est des bons copains, entre nous il se passera jamais rien.
Pour moi t'es juste un pote assexué.
C'est bon ça va, exagère pas trop non plus...
C'est toujours bon d'avoir un pote, quelqu'un sur qui compter.
Qui fait ton repassage et te sert de repose pied.
On a les mêmes goûts, on dirait presque que t'as fait exprès.
Non j't'assure j'adore vraiment le maquillage et Gossip Girl.
T'es la première personne à qui je pense, quand je suis en vacances.
Et que t'as besoin de quelqu'un pour arroser tes plantes.
On est fusionnels, on fait tout comme un petit couple.
A part faire l'amour, ce qui est quand même la base d'un couple.
J'suis dans la friendzone, zone, zone, zone.
Bloqué dans la friendzone, zone, zone, zone.
Je suis destiné à me masturber toute l'éternité.
Je peux te raconter les détails quand je couche avec un mec.
Ça me dérange pas, mais est-ce que t'as des photos pour mieux m'expliquer ?
T'étais là pour me réconforter, le jour où j'me suis fait larguer.
J'me souviens j'avais sorti le champagne et les confettis, babyyy.
T'es mon amigo, mon poto, ma couille, ma petite crotte.
Tu peux rester sur mon prénom initial, ça me va aussi.
On peut dormir ensemble comme des amis dans le même lit.
Par contre, t'as oublié de mettre ton pyjama.
Mais où ai-je la tête ?
J'suis dans la friendzone, zone, zone, zone.
Bloqué dans la friendzone, zone, zone, zone.
Je suis destiné à me masturber toute l'éternité.
Je lui fais des p'tits massages, quand elle en a envie.
Là, ta main est sur mon sein.
Oui mais c'est un massage tibétain.
Tous les deux, on est juste copains, on sait qu'il se passera jamais rien.
Est-ce que tu comptes répéter ça toute la chanson, ça commence à devenir vexant.
Je peux même te raconter mes problèmes de cœur avec mon mec.
Ah, tu t'es remis avec, je savais pas, j'vais marcher un peu sur l'autoroute.
Pour moi, t'es plus qu'un pote, je te considère comme un frère.
Est-ce que tu savais que dans certaines tribus, ils couchent entre frère et soeur ?
- Ah, c'est dégueu..
- Ouais non mais euh, non c'est dégueu ouais..
- Hu-hum alors voilà, j'ai un truc à te dire euh, je me lance.
Ça fait longtemps qu'on se connaît toi et moi..
Et pour moi ce qu'on vit c'est plus que de la simple amitié alors...
Je t'ai fait un petit cadeau.
Je pense que ça te fera très plaisir. Tiens.
- Waouh ! Une bague d'amitié !! Merci, t'es trop gentil !
- Bah non, c'est.. Bah non..
J'suis dans la friendzone, zone, zone, zone.
Bloqué dans la friendzone, zone, zone, zone.
Je suis destiné à me masturber toute l'éternité.
Dans les champs de blé.
J'suis dans la friendzone, zone, zone, zone.
Bloqué dans la friendzone, zone, zone, zone.
Je suis destiné à me masturber toute l'éternité.
Dans la voie lactée.
J'suis dans la friendzone...
Chaque année, des milliers d'hommes et femmes sont friendzonés.
Alors soutenons-les en mettant un pouce en l'air !
Pour l'amour du love.
Au revoir.
Rentrez bien chez vous.
Et si vous êtes déjà chez vous,  continuez bien à être chez vous.
Bye bye.
Je t'aime.